hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play out so we
just met up with the priest that he told
us that we are lucky to not have been
carved up by the crazy psycho doctor and
I know I've been through your a bit
before and there was nothing in here
besides the burning body parts which is
still kind of weird but not relevant to
what we're doing right now so we need to
find a way to meet up with senior priest
demon and we are going into this haunted
locker room of nightmares and Ords
I wonder if there's going to be a big
burly man come thundering down the
hallway for me well nothing good has
happened so far oh come on okay if I
just click the mouse button the doors
open much quicker if I hold it down and
open slowly so I need to utilize that to
the best of my ability who bloody
footprints they end so abruptly oh hello
they kind of lead me up here can I get
outside whoa why is this all on fire
wouldn't the whole facility be burning
down can I get back now oh I guess I was
a one-way trip
right then everything's on fire shit's
on fire yo I'm a Honda ah my finger so I
guess I'm now permitted Oh Mirko took so
much from us yeah used us uh-huh turned
us into these things because nobody
cares about a few forgotten lunatics
Yeah right so let it burn burn the whole
gun
uh-huh okey-dokey if you say so that's
like the most sane thing I've seen so
far wait I haven't read some of these
the big four is stalking me found a
patient file on Chris Walker
okay so necromantic [ __ ] this place
seriously just [ __ ] this place dying
keeps moving lower on the list of worst
things that could happen to me here I
can't shake Chris Walker the big ugly
Brewer that likes to ripping off
people's heads
I hear muttering about security
protocols containment what if he's not
the problem what if he's trying to fix
it oh maybe he is I'm not the only
victim here not by a long shot I watched
a man wait to burn to death the most
painful death imaginable rather than
stay in this place is it the most
painful death imaginable it's I imagine
it's pretty horrific okay so there's a
whole bunch of burning bodies here
maybe that's why the poem the things
were over crawl under it maybe that's
why the limbs were burning in the
bathroom there because this guy just did
that as a precursor I gotta say those
fire effects look really good I mean for
a video game anyway moving on so let's
see what's down here
oh nothing okay Wow all right I wonder
what else can happen to me in the
darkness what awaits me mr. priest what
have you got for me with horrible
diabolical lender I need to find some
more batteries or else I'm gonna run out
really soon well there's a radio I would
have figured a battery would have been
nearby some somber music going on very
different from what it was before
aha here we go give me please thank you
if you're seeing this say something
there's no shame in psychopathological
proximity stress disorder boy talk to
your supervisor to get help from a
Murkoff success counsellor oh if you're
seeing things not seeing this all whoops
oh not crazy
everybody ignore what I just said ignore
it I was seeing that it's said a
different thing than what it was
supposed to
what's going on here teamwork Patrick
put perfect of her weight was I not
supposed to come this way as the whole
place still burning down uh I think I
may have gone the wrong way he said get
out through the kitchen right was I not
going through the kitchen was I not
going through the kitchen it doesn't
look like the kitchen oh the kitchens
over here okay I was making no horrible
error let's see figure out how to get
I'm surprised to tell things Wow Oh woah
oh good golly that hurt never get out
through the kid no I was going the right
way
I had to be going the right way I'm just
I'm just a giant lunatic and don't know
what I'm doing with my life
Oh squeeze through the gap little piggy
little piggy little piggy little piggy
go home get a little piggy no no don't
get me a little bit little piggy okay so
here we go into the darkness what is
that
okay that's a tub of something okay okay
yeah it's dark not dark in here oh don't
tell me I got up oh I got a turn on two
valves which means that something's
gonna be stalking me through the halls
whoa whoa what is that oh it's the
deadlock that big guys like to rip
people's heads off okay I'm gonna hide
I'm gonna be super stealthy like a
shadow in the night like a shadow in the
night that's going the wrong freakin way
I'm an idiot you'll never find me
you'll never find me no always gonna
find me about it are you doing looking
good you're looking fit fat man you lift
bro do you even lift
alright so we're just gonna carry on
nice and slowly
not to believe he wants to rip my head
off I do believe I don't like that okay
he must have come from an area where a
valve was gonna be where is he Oh dead
body the whole party going on what is
that guy holding up he's bashing down a
door somewhere over there okay so I just
need to not be over there say where's
this valve is that a squeezy hole okay
no little piggy no no no little piggy
your home will peek you're gonna run
away little pig you're gonna have a good
old time wait a minute what the hell
what is this Wow what's that oh you're
alive never tell when something to live
my term for what
bathtime
is so horrific that's insanity
that's beyond insanity so does one of
these bodies have a key that I need is
at the feel oh man oh wait no no I'm
here this is the thing yeah sweet bro
all right so it's like this game is just
nothing but total insanity
who's your clean baby Wow okay man that
is weird little piggy no no no piggy
little piggy no no little pig you're
home okay I'm gonna keep saying that
every time I go through a gap because
I'm Fred oh that's my shadow how strange
wait I hear him oh my god
go away please I need to go that way you
don't see me Oh word what what what
okay
did he go hey why is the music still
blaring okay
did he find a way around I have no idea
okay the music's dying down looks like
he lost me or I lost him whoa I hear him
I hear him I hear a harem of him okay I
don't know where he went I really don't
know where he went I just got to be a
bit more careful before turning the
corner and running smack into him I
think maybe that room over there laundry
room there might be aa Val need to get
in there you change out my battery and
if some guys were confused the battery
only drains when my night vision is on
that's the only time the battery drained
otherwise the camera is very useful to
have up because I can zoom with the
camera to try to see what I need I still
hear him I'm just gonna be crawling okay
all right we're good
just I'm in their hiding spot okay
there's a hiding spot over there oh it's
dark oh it's dark all right
that's a valve I got this [ __ ] why do I
need to turn this on oh because I'm
putting out the fire oh my god oh my god
oh oh whoa
you rip my head off
you rip my head off why did he rip my
head off that was not fair you like they
intentionally did that oh man oh how
many valves do I need to open now I
gotta get both valves that's dumb
ah man okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna be super stealthy about this
we're gonna hide while he's still in the
shadows I'm gonna go very stealthily and
not I keep doing that that's the reason
I died is because I sprinted right into
the core no keep going straight keep
going straight bro keep going straight
going straight bro go straight bro
I'm not down there little piggy that way
little piggy Go Go aah
even better choice away from both of the
directions that I wanted you to go I'm
actually gonna close this door behind me
so I know if he barges in aah
don't slam it shut you can't close it
djibouti Mouse I've heard that whatever
I want him to hear it oh there's a
locker to hide in
eyes are coming huntin
you'll never find me in this one locker
he'll never find me
no never buy my little piggy not here
little bit you'll go yeah that's right
hey ho run away run away like the scared
baby that you is did he leave did he
actually leave I think you left yeah
John ok so just double check be sure I
don't want to be caught again these guys
Sam you guys see them write in the
comments below if you see them like
favorite and subscribe if you see them
don't forget to leave a comment in the
comment section below
ok anyway
cat I'll Sam only gonna join the Tea
Party of dead Tea Party of the Dead that
would make a great band Oh someone take
that give me 25 percents every time you
say a word Tea Party of the Dead oh it's
just a great name ah - great now no one
can take that actually I'm gonna take
that for myself
no one can have that that's mine and
mine alone Tea Party of the Dead hey
buddy you so big and so strong your
muscles are bulging out everywhere oh my
shadow is gonna splay out yeah I'm a
monster
okay anyway squeeze through the gap I'm
safe behind the gap that's what people
thought when they went shopping for
clothes and then they got murdered
someone's very dirty Haiti I'm sure here
all right got the bolt sprinklers
sprinklers okay he came after me when I
came out of here - who's right around
the corner so I just need to be careful
about this I don't want to die again
enough to do this all over the place I'd
rather hit keep my head attached to my
body if that's
is he there is he there little piggy no
no oh you didn't see anything you didn't
see anything what was that oh no I
better get back to my biscuits and gravy
I'm really hungry cleaning up this
entire Hospital ripping the heads off of
people is a hard job but somebody's
kinda Jewish oh it's my teddy bear I
want to give him a nice big hug
I would never rip the head off of my
little teddy bear Oh daddy someone
making fun of me over there run off time
okay it's gone so anyway that was enough
mocking the giant muscular guy that's
gonna rip my head off and instead what
we're gonna do we're gonna slip by him
Oh so secretively and we're gonna get
there I'm if I understand his patrol
routes he's gonna go back to the way he
came and then I'm gonna loop he's gonna
come back towards me yep Oh
see uh-huh he stopped over there he's
like who's that who you making funny
much anywhere you like a lemur if I
smash your head off that's right that's
right yeah but it's fine father Martin
outside I'm guessing that all the Flyers
are out now like a little bit you know
no little piggy go home all right Wow
oh pretty horrific if I do say so myself
okay is this all did that guy burned to
death or did I save him in time why
didn't I just let the whole place burned
down I would have loved to let the whole
place burned down that guy's dead he was
over here somewhere where'd he go
oh I like that music okay so anyway
where's that oh that's that's a kitchen
cart okay nevermind so I I'm just about
all the time for this one thank you all
so much for watching click here and
takes more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
didn't wanna response
really okay that's a lot
you know I mean usually video games
especially handling
can't use it that way but I would be
able to pass through the Sigma they
tried it three times